difficile de ne pas sortir son
porte-monnaie devant tant de belles
choses le marché de créateurs qui s'est
tenue samedi à versailles était
organisée par l'association la
révolution du fait main on pouvait donc
y trouver des lampes des bijoux de la
vaisselle des jouets ou encore des
cosmétiques uniques et originaux la
révolution du fait main pour nous c'est
de dos maux fort la révolution et le
fait main soit parce qu'on a envie dès
aujourd'hui de montrer des petits
créateurs sont là qui font des choses
uniques la manifestation qui a regroupé
une soixantaine de créateurs surf sur le
retour de l'artisanat dans les habitudes
de consommation face à l'envahissement
des grandes enseignes le fait main porte
des valeurs en phase avec notre envie
d'authenticité le vrai travail manuel
pour moi c'est un vrai travail à forte
valeur ajoutée c'est quelque chose dans
lequel on va mettre vraiment tout son
coeur tout son amour c'est quelque chose
qu'on fait combat cloportes pour
l'acheteur participer à un tel marché
offre l'opportunité de se procurer des
pièces uniques d'affirmer son propre
style près de réussite et qui
globalisent beaucoup de choses et qui
uniformise aussi beaucoup de choses
c'est à dire que voilà on peut tous
achetés à très bas prix de la mode et du
design ou des accessoires et que je
pense vraiment quand son on a on a un
réel besoin de retour aux faits main à
l'authenticité a rencontré les créateurs
du lien de la convivialité et des belles
pièces la recette a bien fonctionné à
versailles l'association la révolution
du fait-main souhaite d'ailleurs
organiser d'autres marchés de créateurs
dans la région